[inaudible].
I'm Jad Abumrad today on radiolab.
Robert Krulwich and I are tackling a question which is very big in neuroscience
at the moment. What makes you,
you sounds actually like a childhood question man.
It is except no one really knows the answer for the station Id we heard one
scientist's theory that the self or the mind or even the soul
is nothing but a story of the brain tells itself.
Listening to, what was the name of that guy? Paul Paul Brock. Bob Rocks. Um,
the notion that what you are,
what a self is is just a story you tell has some scientific authority behind it
and that's it. Cause I actually didn't exactly know what he's talking about.
Well vs Ramachandran who is a world famous neurologist also believes that what
is peculiarly human about us is our ability to construct stories.
And he says this ability is new or relatively new.
It happened at a particular moment in time and he thinks he knows about when
maybe 200,000 years ago, half a million years ago,
something absolutely astonishing happened.
What the evolution of introspective consciousness and the evolution of the south
evolution of introspective consciousness. What does that mean? Well,
let's do this simply and back up for a minute.
[inaudible] there are different sets of creatures in the world.
There are dumb ones. There are smarter ones. And then there's us. Okay,
so let's just choose, say a worm for our dumb candidate.
Imagine you're aware and you're crawling through the ground like worms like to
do, and you bump into a pebble. Now, here's what a warm doesn't do.
A warm doesn't think I can't seem to move this pebble [inaudible] because
they're warm.
Doesn't have a brain big enough or a nervous system strong enough to support the
idea of Dang me. Pebble. Certainly not. Dang,
there's no I'm, I'm not a worm.
But as far as vs Ramachandran is concerned inside the worm's head,
there is no picture at all. There's just a set of inherited instincts.
No pictures in that worms head. No story there. Okay?
So let's step up to another level of creature. You give me a creature, uh,
but it has to be a more complex one. Okay. How about going back to the monkey?
Okay. Monkey monkey swinging through trees.
Monkey sees a lady monkey, the lady monkey.
If it has a red, um, how should I put this bottom then the,
the lady monkey is interested in sex. So if you notice, says Dr Ramachandran,
if that rump is red, the red rumps of of a female primates.
I like to eat red.
I claim a monkey after seeing red can react to it.
Maybe you can even remember the red and do the appropriate reaction.
And the probably reaction in this case would be to grab that lady monkey and you
know, might make a baby with her.
This monkey pulls an image of another monkey in, makes an association.
And so there's images in the monkey's head.
But now here's something the monkey can't do.
You can't the symbol red and it's Ed. So if I said to a monkey,
see that Volvo over there, that White Volvo, let's make it a red Volvo.
Any human being can take a white car and make it in their imagination.
You can paste red on it in his imagination, but a monkey you don't think can do.
We cannot. And this is so simple for a human being to do. And I just,
let's run through a quick exercise. Okay. Imagine for me a bird in your head.
Got a bird in there. Yeah. What kind of bird? A canary. Yes.
Now there it's there.
Make it into a brilliantly red canary even though, ah,
okay. Like kind of a cardinal, but canary's Barney, it's there. It's right now.
Make it into a striped canaries. Trapped. What? Color stripes? Purple. Purple.
Purple Stripes. Purple stripes on a Red Canary. Wait, hold up.
Purple stripes on a Red Canary. Got It. Is it in there? Now?
It's there and an l. It's vivid glory. Ornithological stripe.
And this is not one of your favorites. All right,
so at this moment I'm going to point out something to you.
There is no such thing as a purple striped red. The canary in the world.
You could search the world and never find one that does not surprise me,
but you've got one now in your head. However lamely it's in there somewhere.
Only a human being could do this because only humans can take images from the
real world, pull them into their heads, divide them into parts,
and then start turning those parts into abstractions. Monkeys does.
Ramachandran can't do that.
A monkey can be trained to think of a bird putting the bell in, show it a bud,
and the fifth time you just ring a bell.
Presumably it's conjuring up an image for bud.
Now you can not only train a human to think of the bad,
you can train a human to think of babies,
but now the human can think of a birds wings on a human baby conjured an angel,
which has never seen this is because he is now has what are called Tokens.
He has created design body tokens.
So color is Hogan big is it took adjectives or adjectives or tokens and then he
can manipulate these tokens,
juxtapose them in counterintuitive ways.
He can create even outlandish scenarios,
what we call imagination.
Let me see if I can get this straight. Okay,
you've got the worm who can sense the world sort of,
and then you've got the monkey who can pull the world in to some degree and make
an association. Right?
Then you've got us and we can play with those associations. How did,
how did that happen? Well, the cut cause of evolution,
it's like we're not different from other creatures.
We're just more than other creatures and when we have these brains that have
this extra like it's like a layer on layer cake,
we can manipulate any idea at all and we're constantly doing that.
We're constantly abstracting. We are imagining so often,
thoroughly and so well that we eventually can imagine ourselves.
I can sit here looking right at you and I can see you right now as jab,
the little boy if I want, or Jen, y'all dying, man, if I want,
or Jad with a purple stripes and an elegant set of Taffeta wings.
The idea of self, if you think about it this way,
is you take all the things that have ever happened to you, pluck from your life.
If you're sad, you might pick the sad things.
If you're happy on what particular day you might puck the happy things and you
stitch them together into a general abstract idea and me then an idea of self is
really a story that we tell ourselves.
It can change from day to day and it allows the human being to exercise that
peculiarly human muscle to experience stuff.
And then to abstract it into a story that's so
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this is Radiolab. Chad here with Robert Krulwich.
So this makes more sense to me now.
I think this idea that the brain, uh,
spins a story moment to moment as you're walking about.
And that story is you yourself. If it's so automatic,
does it even happen when we sleep? Why do I say that?
Well, I asked Paul Brocks this question and he told me something really strange,
something that made me think that maybe when we're asleep the brain loosens its
grip on the self to self tumbles into a thousand parts
creatures. I don't know what he,
you tell me basically is that when he was young,
he would have these dreams where he'd see these things, these parts of himself.
Presumably the dream would be going along fine, everything would be normal.
And then all of a sudden along would come these little pieces.
Yes. Literally little people, they were,
they were hordes of these little creatures over.
I'd see them in a great pageants or the sweeping vine and occasionally they'd
come up and I've sensed that kind of looking at me. But uh,
but then I'd go away again and I just sort of watch. Do they,
were they were aware of you? Uh,
well that's a very eerie thought cause it's my brain that was producing them,
um, as well as producing me.
That's a strange thing. He, he really means little people. Yeah.
And oddly enough, he discovered he wasn't alone,
which is why I was very fascinated by Robert Louis Stevenson because his
descriptions were very similar to the sort of things that I experienced.
Stevenson.
Do you know the [inaudible] one of the most important writers of the 19th
century? Apparently he saw them too.
The little people who manage mans in total theater.
That's how he describes them in one particular essay.
Read for us here by an actor, Joshua Cain.
For anyone who's ever wondered where do dreams come? Where does
an idea come from? This essay is an interesting read and confusing.
First of all,
Stephenson always refers to himself in the third person as he is honest,
feller war, the dreamer, the dreamer. I'm not sure why.
Maybe it's not so strange considering the rest of the essays about little people
and his mind. Okay. In any case, what he writes is it,
at first the stories they acted out for him were, well,
they didn't make any sense.
The little people play it upon their stage like children rather than like
drilled actors performing a set piece to a huge hole of faces.
Anytime. An interesting thing happens,
Stevenson decides to become a writer to write and sell his tails in things
change.
Yeah.
Was he in here with a little people who did that part of his business in quite a
new conditions.
Now, the little people weren't just the things he saw in his dreams.
They were a business opportunity.
Mm.
See, he was broke always and had to crank out the stories.
So very much in the spirit of the industrial revolution,
he decides to exploit his little people,
turn them into a storytelling factory,
which meant he writes a story.
It was now be trimmed and pad and set up on all fours.
It must run from a beginning to an end and fit with the laws of life.
The pleasure in one word had become a business.
And that not only for the dreamer, but for the little people of his theater,
they understood the change as well as he
[inaudible].
So then what happens? Well, he needs stories.
He can sell [inaudible] so he trains this little people.
This is what he writes in his essay. He trains them. W what do you mean? Well,
he had this elaborate pre bedtime ritual. He would, uh, lie on the bed,
feet off, raise one arm, close his eyes,
raises his arm. Yeah,
it was a signal for the little people of his mind to tell him a story.
And Man, you better be a good one.
And behold at once,
little people begin to buster themselves in the same quest and labor all night
long.
When he did not realize was just how good they could be.
Here is one exactly as it came.
It seemed this time that the dreamer was the son of a very rich and wicked man.
The owner of broad acres and the most damnedable temper.
The son had been living abroad on purpose to avoid his father.
When he returned, it was the find his father married again to a young wife.
Because of this marriage, as the dreamer indistinctly Yadda stood.
It was desirable for the father and son to have a meeting.
Yet both being proud in both angry, neither would condescend on a visit,
but meet they did accordingly.
In a desolate sandy country by the sea to the shore, please drive it. Yes,
I'm there. They quarreled. How dare you.
You selfish and the stung by some intolerable insults struck the father.
Oh,
no. Suspicion was aroused. The dead man was found and buried.
The dreamer succeeded to the broadest states, to the rigging, to the rigging,
and found himself installed under the same roof with his father's widow.
Good evening,
Marilyn, will you join me for separate? Thank you.
These two lift very much alone as people may after bereavement sat down to the
table together. Trio, long evenings, Randy? Yes, please.
And Group daily, better friends.
The West Garden is so lovely this time of year. Yes.
Lumtree gone to Flower Omega? Yes. Do you recall it? Yes. Yes.
I used to climb it as a boy.
Really thought I'd teach you how to climb trees. No.
No, he didn't until it seem to him.
Suddenly the Jews prying about dangerous matters,
but he had conceived a notion of his guilt. Rotary watched him,
tried him with questions, so they lived at cross purposes in life.
Have a look broken dialogue, challenging glances and suppressed passion.
Until one day he saw the woman slipping from the house in a veil facing.
Yes ma'am.
You followed her by train to the seaside country and out over the sandhills to
the fairly place where the murder was done. Yeah.
She began to grow up among the fence.
Watching her flat upon his face present to be something in,
this is hint come up with number one applies,
but it was deadly evidence against the dreamer.
I've actually held it up to me credit perhaps from the shock of the discovery or
foot slipped and you can get some pedal on the brink of the tall sample use.
[inaudible] you have no thought with a spring up in rescue. Huh?
Take my hand there. They stood face to face.
She went back.
Deadly matter openly in our hand is very present on the spot.
Another link of proof he was playing, she was about to speak.
This was more than he could bear. Come and he cut us short.
The conversation had to be going.
He passed the evening of the drawing room as in the past. [inaudible] yes,
please. Thank you.
About to spend some fear drummed. The dream was bosom.
Why is she not announce me? I think when Lucia,
so his thoughts ran once indeed he seats an occasion when she was a fraud.
You're ransacked from gluten getting it.
And at last he didn't know way among the Jews found the damning evidence.
Very stood holding this thing,
which was his life in the hollow of his hand and marveling at her behavior that
she should seek and keep. And yet not use it.
Then the door open and behold herself.
Oh,
cool. What's, what are you doing? What are you doing?
Once more, they stood eye to eye with the evidence between them.
Right before he left the room,
he laid back down his death warrant where he had founded at that her face lit
up.
[inaudible] the next he HUD, she was lying to her mate. [inaudible] happens.
You're a real robbery. Oh No, no, no. It's nothing.
It's I'm embarrassed. Really. I, I thought I'd lost something
then. You see, I was looking at me.
Flesh and blood could bear the strain no longer,
and I think it was the next morning though.
Chronology has always hazy in the theater of the mind,
but he burst from his reserve. No thank you. Your team.
Please show that please. You'll be all right.
No sooner with the seven squad and these two protagonists alone together,
but he leaped to his feet. Three to sprang up with a paddle face.
I'm not denouncing me. You'd know everything. Why do you torture me?
Fell upon her knees and with outstretched hands.
Dan, I love you.
Oh,
[inaudible] uniform with a pint of wonder and looking tired, delight, dreamer.
Oh, whoa.
My auntie's mercantile delight is not of long insurance.
As it became plain that in this spirited tale, they will unmarketable elegance.
Ultimately,
Robert Louis Stevenson found this story unusable and he couldn't sell it.
But there's a deeper question here. The question of Authorship,
let's think about it in more modern terms. When you see moving lights go down,
you settle in from one moment to the next,
you the viewer have no idea what's going to happen.
You scream at the scary parts, laugh at the jokes, cry during the sad scenes.
You take it on a ride, but in order for you to have that experience,
someone needed to write the movie, someone needed to direct it,
someone other than you.
How is it when we dream that we do all three at the same time?
We write direct and watch the films. If you've never seen it before,
the little people are substantive inventors and performers. To the end,
they had kept a secret, the dream or had no guests,
whatever the motive of the woman,
the hinge of the whole well invented plot until the instant of the traumatic
revelation was not his tail, it was the little peoples.
I am awake now and I know this trade and yet I cannot better it.
The more I think of it, the more I am moved
the press upon the world. My question,
who all the little people. Okay.
It's almost like watching a video.
You could sort of go and inspect their activities,
scrutinize their activities very closely.
That's how neurologist Paul Brocks describes his little people dreams.
And it kind of fascinated me that this was part of me,
part of my brain activity, but not me. Um, so which,
which part of my brain activity is me
and if it seems there's a bit of a Jekyll and Hyde quality to the mystery of the
little people, that is no coincidence. On another night,
our dreamer Robert Louis Stevenson, once again captivated by the little people,
screamed so loudly, his wife wakes him, Robert, Robert Dialing Waco.
What's wrong? He was not pleased. Damn it. Woman.
I had been dreaming a fine bogey tail, but he didn't manage to remember.
If you thinks from the dream one a scene at the window,
then a man pursued for a crime and that man takes a potion and undergoes a
transformation.
That man's name of course would become Mr. Hyde and our dreamer Robert Louis
Stevenson, the author of that classic tale of a divide itself.
[inaudible]
the story of Robert Louis Stevenson is a little people came from an essay from
Paul Brocks from his excellent book into the silent land and it was adapted for
radio by Ellen Horn.
Joshua Kane was the voice of Robert Louis Stevenson from his essay,
a chapter on dreams and he had a supporting cast of Lorraine Mattox,
John Henry Boudreaux, Frank Podro, Nick Kappa [inaudible], Sally,
her ships and Keith Scott. And if anyone was listening closely,
they would have also recognized you [inaudible] which on that CCI cliff diet,
Diet. Here's the thing.
What is hard to recognize?
If you take a look into somebodies brain and you asked the question,
which we've been asking this whole hour,
like you know who's there or where is the author or where is the,
where am I?
The story points up that if you look scientifically into a brain,
what you encounter is hundreds of thousands of players,
not just little people but teeny, teeny, teeny,
teeny brain cells which do all this flashing back and forth.
If you were to go to any one of those cells and say,
so are you the author of chuckle and hide,
the cell wouldn't would just
write this vocabulary of a neuron. It's just on wrong.
It is only in the group that you can see the electrical outline of a thought,
but ultimately of a self. While you think of yourself as a,
even the thought,
I am a one springs from 100 million cells connecting 2 trillion synapses and
that all of this multiple activity paradoxically creates the,
you have this moment, you are always plural,
[inaudible] and that's especially true in the story we have coming up for you.
In 60 seconds. This is Radiolab, Mum, Jab, Homerun, Robert Crow, which,
and I will continue in a moment.
You're listening to radio on New York public radio, public radio.
W N was.